first on CBS Planned Parenthood is
announcing the opening of a new mega
facility close to states where abortion
access is restricted the new clinic was
built in secret in Illinois near the
Missouri border missourah has some of
the strictest abortion laws in the
country CBS news reporter Kate Smith
visited the facility as it was being
built she's been reporting on abortion
issue since last year kate welcome to
the table and start us off what's a
significant significance rather of this
new clinic I keep hearing it's ginormous
and big exactly so in recent months
states across the South and Midwest
they've been implementing stricter and
stricter anti-abortion laws but this new
clinic is in Illinois
where the state is moving in the
opposite direction so this is the site
of our brand new building here in
Illinois we first visited the new clinic
in August the sensitive project was
being built in secret under the codename
Alaska dr. Colleen McNicholas showed us
around we know that our colleagues at
other Planned Parenthood's and
independent abortion clinics across the
country have had difficulty opening new
clinics and things as simple as getting
the phone company to come in and put
phone and data lines things like the
cabinetmakers not showing up to deliver
once they knew that that facility was
going to be an abortion facility the 18
thousand square foot building cost
nearly seven million dollars to build
Planned Parenthood estimates the new
office can handle up to 11,000 patients
a year the clinic is only miles from the
Missouri border it's positioned to
accommodate patients from nearby states
with strict abortion laws in the last
two years the number of women crossing
the Illinois border for abortions has
more than doubled on a personal level I
just have it in my heart to serve women
Mary Kay nor is executive director of
Illinois right to life the purpose of
Allah is to set a moral standard for
society nor says she's disgusted
Illinois has become what she calls the
abortion capital of the Midwest it's a
travesty that this is happening in our
state it's a travesty that women come
here to get an abortion McNicholas says
Planned Parenthood is committed to
giving their patients the access they
need why did you choose that location
the truth is that our patients want
easier access and for some the 13 mile
drive from our st. Louis clinic
- this Illinois clinic is an opportunity
for them to get that care with less
judgment with less restriction and with
far fewer hoops to jump through CBS News
has learned that the Seoul Planned
Parenthood left in Missouri is planning
to double its clinic escorts
starting today now this is in case of
preparation and backlash to that new
Illinois facility so it was a secret
it's not a secret anymore Bravo on the
reporting I'm curious is Planned
Parenthood of concern about security
they are concerned about security and
it's I should have mentioned not just
security here but security all over the
nation of these providers we've seen a
record high number in violent acts
against abortion providers so it's a
very real threat for these people
they're getting a lot of business they
are getting a lot of business so as we
said you know a number of women crossing
the border into Illinois
to seek an abortion that's more than
doubled and their existing facilities
they just can't handle it we were at one
of those it was in a little strip mall
you know you had to back up in order for
someone to come by and we're gonna see
the capacity more than double with this
new facility and even with that though
we should point out that nationally
abortion is at an all-time low
that's exactly right down yes thank you
very much we appreciate it